in five four three two one pump up a
bomb pop up a bomb genius brain you
[ __ ] what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast I hope your week has fared you
well you know every Thursday it's gonna
be me and Joe talking our [ __ ] let's
attack I like a lot of [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] needy sons of [ __ ] any help
the rescue you know the interesting
thing is this whole like giving people
podcast topics things was something that
I was gonna do every now and then but it
seems like a lot of people actually just
want you guys just want to hear I
wouldn't say advice but just our
thoughts and our takes on things because
we're you know we can I give you an
unbiased opinion yeah about your things
that's going on so when you guys join
the patreon and you ask these questions
or topics if it's very specific to what
you're going through be specific about
it I like the long stories yeah give us
the long story because if not then we're
just going to have to fill in our own
blake's and make assumptions because
that just becomes well sometimes because
I read a couple of comments where
they're like whoa you don't know the
whole story
of course I don't [ __ ] although I got
a paragraph you [ __ ] I mean we're
kind of left to assume yeah so let's
start with the first one today no
[ __ ]
let's start with lacoya Tyler shoutouts
that name that's [ __ ] dope lacoya
sounds like a [ __ ] fizzy drink [ __ ]
oh yeah oh yeah sweet Latoya telecoil
mmm so my ex-fiance stepped out of our
relationship emotionally back around the
end of March
/ beginning of April we had a fight mmm
for several things the biggest be is
being because he got pissed off and
equated my dirty dancing with my married
best girlfriend who has two kids
he quit I don't know what that means yes
she considers herself by but I am NOT
her type when it comes to females also
he got jealous that they did they got
too intimate and dancing a little dirty
dancing dirty dance and the other thing
was the other thing was the point level
contention was that I urged him to go to
counseling he had a lot of childhood
trauma
and had two breakdowns after getting
super drunk in the year and at the time
two months we had been together one
lasting for four hours during which time
he rapidly said he didn't want to be a
person and then and that he was a number
of super negative things I basically
told him that I didn't feel comfortable
marrying him if he didn't take
counseling serious and gain some kind of
coping mechanisms to deal with all the
stress will [ __ ] in his life sounds
reasonable
mm-hmm the next day he left me a
two-page letter that was basically just
a man tantrum and he had my promise ring
sitting on top of the letter waiting for
me when I got home from a 16-hour shift
at work apparently this is when he
turned to his boss who's 10 years older
than him
has a kid and had hung out with me
several times before and I found out
that I would find out what was going on
movies dinners lunches bowling karaoke
drinks etc for support I guess I'm just
trying to figure it out if I was wrong
and pushing the counseling thing I mean
I know that it's not my fault for the
cheating but I would love to have your
advice on this it's hard knowing that
they're dating that they're dating and
in a relationship when I was just
finalizing plans for our wedding thank
you so her fiance was dating his boss is
that what was going on let's see because
it sounds like that's what she was
saying
at the Italian yeah the boss he turned
to his bot to the boss who's 10 years
old of him yeah yeah so like he was a
gay guy or like a like a sugar mama or
whatever like situation like I don't
know what the gender of the boss is
probably female because it seems that
he's getting jealous trait seems like
that's what it is because he felt weird
about her bisexual homegirl Oh lining up
on her I would have been horny that's
what I like I don't know how I would
feel about that cuz if I see like let's
say it's it's it's like because if he
was by I'd get why he's jealous because
but I'm a you know straight guys are
[ __ ] stupid we'll look at that and go
we automatically assume that we're
invited to the party right alright so
I'm gonna I'm gonna see two [ __ ]
right it's interesting cuz like like
hold on girl oh she's mad at that I
wasn't invited to the Dirty Dancing to
watch yeah like what the [ __ ]
man she also said that it wasn't
physical cheating sorry I left that out
okay oh that's a big part of freaking
evidence yeah so though he so he [ __ ]
the the boss basically also he [ __ ]
the boss they've been having like this
dating relationship thingy yeah and then
what what does she call out like they
had restaurant like dates basically
dates right movie and all that and all
he was saying is like no it's it's just
yeah I think this is my just this is not
advice but this is just my personal take
on everything yeah I just think like
there's already a lot of [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up here a lot of [ __ ] mm-hmm the
trust is violated you guys don't seem to
be able to communicate because you know
you you're saying one thing he doesn't
understand it and he writes like a
two-page letter yeah he doesn't that
means he doesn't feel understood right
so obviously like you sound sensible
like what you said like most people when
there's talking their points they
usually are right of mine yeah but then
I don't know how you are when you're
emotionally route up and you're talking
to them in a different way or whatever
like I don't know um
I think the main thing that I've seen in
all relationships though is when people
tell their story they're always right
and they're the [ __ ] hero yeah
not saying that she's not at she's not
she's not really doing that in an
egotistic way but they don't know what
they did wrong is what I'm saying it's
like people be like man I I said this
and you know and it's you go yeah that
sounds reasonable but we all know in a
relationship like that there's one thing
when people tell the story back and then
there's what actually happened yeah if I
was like a ghost and I was watching that
[ __ ] both of those [ __ ] like
both couples they would go back and tell
their friends some other [ __ ] yeah and
what really happened 100% and you know
was interesting cuz I think she's also
asking too from what I read she's I
think she feels at fault for pressuring
him to go into counseling to make him
feel a certain way and maybe she's
looking back at and saying like if I
hadn't done this he wouldn't have poor
girl which which is nothing to do with
asking for counselling it's it's he
might so here I think the cheating thing
is is this
like when people cheat that's their
problem it's never you right
like some people cheat because they need
constant validation or they you know
they miss the vacation feeling in a
relationship like you know when you're
pursuing someone some guys are just
addicted to pursuing and conquering yeah
so when you are in a relationship and
they don't feel the dynamic has changed
and they feel like they can't pursue you
because they won you or there's just
other reasons why and here's someone
else who's giving them attention here's
someone else that doesn't see the faults
here's someone else that looks at him as
a man as someone that's like amazing and
like and it's like infatuated with them
and they get addicted to that attention
yeah and it's also - it's weird for her
in lacoya
life for you like you shouldn't look at
it like this like for example in this
situation I feel like you feel that
you're pressuring him the counseling was
a catalyst for him to cheat if he was
gonna cheat he was gonna cheat either
way yeah that's the thing with cheaters
yeah
they cheat either way that that was
going to happen whether it was this or
it was something else now the problem
with this especially in this type of
behavior like he writes this whole 16
page existing page like diet ripening or
whatever after right it's a whole novel
exactly you know for him I think a lot
of people are scared of counseling
because in order for you to go to
counseling or therapy you also have to
admit that there's something wrong with
you yeah and a lot of people can't do
that they can't go to counseling because
that means they have to openly admit
that hey look I'm kind of [ __ ] up and
I need some help yeah because in a lot
of the times even for me I feel like oh
I don't need counseling because I I know
what I'm doing wrong I don't need
somebody to tell me that I'm already
[ __ ] up I know that I'm [ __ ] up I
know I need counseling I just don't
respect the counselor I've been dude
I've been into some rooms where I'm like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I need to
get out of here that's the problem cuz
also I have a psychology degree right so
I mean it's just a bachelor's it's not a
[ __ ] but the thing is sometimes that
[ __ ] you up when you know too much it's
like you're a filmmaker right you made
films and [ __ ] that [ __ ] you up when
you go into the theater you can't just
enjoy for what it is yeah so it's almost
like I don't know I'm like maybe I had a
nursing degree right you kind of look at
your doctor a little bit different
mm-hmm cuz you know if they're [ __ ] up
or not and you don't wait a minute that
doesn't seem right yeah so you hold them
up to a higher standard and I think
that's where I [ __ ] up when I walk in
the room I try my best to do it right
and just kind of like walking with no
bias but as I start seeing the laziness
I start seeing their problem I start
seeing them like going you're not
engaged you're this is a paycheck for
you this is a mucking job for you I'm
out yeah you know or like I just I don't
know man so that's that's my issue with
a lot of counseling and techniques yeah
and methods and things like that that I
might not agree with I know too damn
much yeah but you're right a lot of
people when they go the [ __ ] nothing's
wrong with me I don't need to [ __ ] go
or just maybe it's the way she did it
mm-hmm maybe it's the way she's like
something's wrong with you or I don't
know like I don't know how she really
did it you know but that's a touchy
thing to talk about but I had I
guarantee you has nothing to do with the
[ __ ] cheating mm-hmm because I have
friends that love their women absolutely
love their women mm-hmm but they can't
resist cheating yeah because they love
touching a lot of women just it's a
physical thing sometimes but yeah I also
think it's like an issue that they have
to deal with because they like they
wanna be like they want to be wanted all
this [ __ ] or I don't know man there's
just something with it this podcast is
brought to you by purple I'm saying
purple baby the thing that has been
helping me sleep so well at night the
mattress that is the perfect perfect
density I'm talking about firm and soft
at the same time I keep saying firm and
soft at the same time because it's hard
to explain what type of bed your body
needs until you sleep on a purple
mattress my whole life I've been
sleeping on these boxspring pieces of
crap and I gotta tell you especially as
an Asian kid people were telling me that
you have to sleep on something really
hard for your back and lo and behold I
was completely wrong I was hurting my
joints so many pressure points on my
back and the purple mattress relieved
all of them literally the best night
sleeps I've ever had in my life never
never never ever before have I slept as
well and it was because I was sleeping
on a really bad mattress
I needed something that can keep me cool
because I sweat a lot at night man do I
sweat a lot and the technology behind
this is amazing because it was developed
by rocket scientists and can I say
something people if you're getting bad
sleep you probably cranky and you're
probably not happy like me so get that
purple mattress and let me tell you
something man you're going to love
purple and right now my listeners will
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is the text
brain two eight four - eight eight eight
that's B are AI n - eight four eight
eight eight message and data rates may
apply there's also this thing of you
know when sometimes people just don't
know how to cope with their with
problems very well so their their quick
reaction to it like a marital problem is
for them to find solace and comfort into
somebody else right and dealing with the
problem head-on and we've seen this time
and time before words like oh if you're
you know we see this [ __ ] in meme
culture - and Twitter cultures like if
you can't find a woman or man that
satisfies you there's no be somebody
else that'll do it no they won't
you know and it's temporary it's
temporary these these these fixes are
temporary like you think that if you
bounce from this one my mom said it the
best
well Mary and I were going through a lot
of problems when so like I don't post
too much about Muriel and when I do it's
something positive because I feel it at
the moment and I want to show her love
whether it's at a public forum or it's
personal but the you know Jo knows - and
me and Muriel's first two years we were
fighting all the [ __ ] time we could
not [ __ ] get along we would always
cry to each other about how much I
thought were that girlfriends yeah [ __ ]
these [ __ ] did yeah and you know when
I was telling my mom I was like you know
I don't think I could be with this girl
and this was like year two and I and I
really feel like you know I gotta find
somebody else that understands me more
mom said was you know I keep hearing
your problems and your griping in your
bitching about these stuff and I was
like you're you're what you're
complaining about is what every couple
goes through when you're in a monogamous
relationship she goes your problems that
you have with her is not gonna be fixed
with the next girl you'll fight these
same fights yeah with this other person
so if you want to be in a relationship
you have to understand what it entails
and you also have to understand that you
have to fight for it to a certain extent
if it was a problem like her
you know I don't know I forgot what the
example she gave me was but like her you
know spending all your money that's
different you know she goes but if it's
a problem of her annoying you you you
spend enough time with anybody they're
gonna [ __ ] annoy you yeah that's true
you know it's not true it's not a
quality that's unique to her and there's
a lot of people to who I've met that
openly have come out to I used to live
with this one person where they're
they're married now and I lived with
them and it was so funny because I would
hear her conversation I remember we were
all talking and stuff and I'm not
relationships [ __ ] I was in a serious
relationship at the time and she goes I
don't know why people just don't stay
with how can people stay with somebody
that they argue with me and my husband
we never argue and I've looked dead in
this bitch's soul and I was like I
[ __ ] live with you you fight all the
[ __ ] time what are you talking about
it's like it's his delusion delusional
she's like we never fight I just
repressed all the fights memories so I
don't have any fights in my head I'm
telling you when I see a couple that
that is always lovey dovey in front of
us in public I know there's some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] behind doors there's so there's
there's no reason for not wouldn't say
any reason but if if that's how the
image that you're trying so hard to
protect for everybody else to see
then there's definitely something going
on behind doors I'm not saying that's
how it is all the time but that's what
I've seen and now this couple two that I
know of
they're know they're in [ __ ] hot
water right now and they're so they and
they will always openly tell people how
amazing their relationship was how they
never [ __ ] fight well not not the guy
but she would and it was the complete
opposite a complete disaster and in
their case you know she cheated on him
so so it was like because there's such a
happy couple that never fights right
exactly so she just needed to go out and
cheat because there's no problems yeah
it's stupid it's such a weird phenomenon
and I think people want to project this
idea of what they are versus who they
actually are what their life is really
like and there's a lot of dishonesty you
know when your guys's case to you know
the counseling thing probably scared
them I don't think that you should feel
guilty for asking for him to go to
counseling but people if you know that
your partner is very damaged then you
also have to know how to communicate
with somebody knowing the [ __ ] that they
went through if you know that this
has had a [ __ ] up past right you got a
[ __ ] tippy-toe around it yeah what's
your approach now yeah you sometimes
it's a selfish thing because it's like
so this is what I realized and this is
just just coming from me like how what I
went through is like when you see
someone drowning and you want to save
them right like you it's like sure you
could jump in the water and pull them
out but then like what ends up happening
is like people are so selfish because in
reality what they want to do is they
want to they want to rescue them because
they're hurt about it yeah like it hurts
watching someone you know pretty much
walk off a cliff or whatever so you want
to save them because it's making you
stressed out right but in reality like
you're not doing that you're not doing
them a favor at their pace you're
rushing them you're telling them [ __ ]
hurry up and get it over with and you're
like aggressive about it you're like
you're you're putting too much pressure
on them like an annoying parent right
and the reason why is because you're not
doing it you know you're not doing a
service to them you're doing a service
to yourself ultimately yeah cuz you're
just like hurry up and fix your [ __ ] so
I don't worry anymore yeah that's what's
happening you're like a worried mom that
wants their kid to come home and be safe
but is it really because the kids safety
or is it because you're worrying so
[ __ ] much and you're being selfish
about it hmm so I think when it comes to
that people always Minoo they go oh this
is you know for you like it's it's for
you but in reality it's because you
don't want to worry that much you don't
want to feel like you're second-guessing
anything and all that and then you're
threatening the marriage like if you
don't get counseling then we don't get
married and I'm like I get it but
there's also the other part of like
unconditional love where you know what
you're getting yourself into
and what that that shows me is like you
better fix your [ __ ] then I'll love you
mmm versus like you know what I know
you're a broken piece of [ __ ] but I
[ __ ] love you and I'm gonna ride this
out no matter how long it takes if it
takes 20 years to fix your [ __ ]
problems then I'll be there for you but
people don't have that loyalty so they
don't know how to do it and then I'm
guilty of that too right that's
when I noticed like oh [ __ ] dude like I
I don't know how to love someone
unconditionally yeah everything is a is
a is a like if you do this right then
I'll love you and I think that's how a
lot of people operate and that's no way
to do it yeah yeah it's it's it's hard
for like I understand too when you're in
the beginning of your relationship and
you want to figure out what's right for
you
so you're it does come from an art you
know arguably uh I think a sensible
selfish place where you're thinking
about your future and the person that
you're gonna be with and that's
understandable it's just sometimes when
you when you give somebody ultimatums
you push them into a corner yeah and
when you push them to a corner people
can't help but fight back because it's
like wait hold on a second what do you
mean you're not gonna if I don't take
this that you're gonna leave me so
that's all it really takes and then
you're just gonna [ __ ] bounce there's
a lot of problems in like approach and
how how you deal with people because
everybody comes with a certain amount of
baggage that we all have to learn how to
deal with like you know Joe and I were
just talking about this when we were
having lunch about how much your parents
can [ __ ] you up for the future and that
[ __ ] starts to bleed out and it'll leak
out when you're older and it's and it
sucks because we have to deal with and
maybe my kids in the future too they
have to deal with my inadequacies yeah
and I pushed onto them and they don't
even know what it is until they're older
they're like no I'm a reflection of my
parents and humans are just emotional
sponges we soak up we observe we take on
the habits of other people were way more
like what do you call it like we absorb
feelings and habits more than we know oh
yeah like you start talking like people
like when you're around them you start
thinking like them you start that's why
they say like you are the five closest
people around you and what typically
happens is like when you remove yourself
from this [ __ ] group and you get to a
next group and then they make more money
or like they make better decisions you
start to absorb that [ __ ] you start to
build their habits and then like so on
and so on but like well going back to
the whole like parent [ __ ] it's like you
spend the years absorbing that right and
then I think the whole point of a
relationship and a loving relationship
is being able to be with a partner that
will deal with that [ __ ] baggage and
then
put up with it but help you grow out of
it and then we spend the rest of our
lives undoing those mistakes or undoing
those bad habits that are damaging to
ourselves and the people around us yeah
so in her case man like I I'm also kind
of harsh on her but I don't I don't
think anything is her fault because
she's not she doesn't know right that's
why she's asking these questions I'm
just saying I'm just speaking from what
I've done wrong yeah and you know maybe
you know people that are listening can
learn from it hopefully so they don't
end up in a broken relationship like you
know what I just went through and just
looking back at it I'm like oh [ __ ] I
there was a lot of things where I [ __ ]
up and going forward into a new
relationship I think I understand better
you know how to set up better
expectations for myself so so so like it
doesn't let myself down and doesn't like
the other person down yeah because when
you like like the ultimatums we know
people who go all right like let's let's
settle this right and in and then
they'll talk about it in their
relationship
and then the guy will promise and the
girl will be like all right cool
but it's a false expectation because how
are you gonna undo 20-something years of
a bad habit overnight over one
discussion that's unfuckin reasonable
yeah yeah if this person's been late for
the last 15 years of their lives and you
have one discussion and you expect your
husband to be early on time it's like
nah like but don't get emotional about
it don't take it personal as if they're
lying to you don't take it personal as
if they failed you don't take it like
they're [ __ ] there it's like people
will make promises because they wanna do
good right so they'll say [ __ ] like all
right honey I won't be late anymore
whatever right and then he's gonna break
that promise why cuz he's been a late
[ __ ] for the last 15 years or
like or a cheater or a [ __ ] whatever
habit they have right but if you want to
save this relationship you can't react
immediately go see I know you're a lying
sack of [ __ ] [ __ ] you yeah you know you
hurt my [ __ ] feelings and it's like
there's no progress that can ever happen
the job for the person is to accept the
fact that hey the person you're with is
a broken piece of [ __ ] but you gotta
love them uncle
additionally to help them and remind
them and teach them and over and over it
happens over and over all right you're
late that's cool man next time let's try
to do and then you create parameters
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] it sucks but that's
a part of being human and I think that's
how you grow a good relationship man I
need you to talk to Muriel about the
toilet seat thing then because I've been
trying to explain that that's a very
good wet okay I'm gonna take this
podcast and I'm gonna put it in her
[ __ ] ear because this is what I've
been trying to tell her about my toilet
seat problem so so we move into a new
place we have one big bathroom that
makes it personal as if you're not
listening to her exactly so I've been
telling her this man [ __ ] Marian you're
gonna listen to this [ __ ] and I swear to
God so I was telling her she goes I see
she goes you know how much I hate this
you I hate it when you leave the toilet
seat up and what I was telling her was
this I was like listen my whole life
I've never had to do this Yeah right
my mom whether the toilet seat was up or
down she didn't give a [ __ ] she would
just put it down and she would put it up
it was never a [ __ ] issue cuz it
wasn't something in your household it
wasn't in my house she didn't have any
brothers or sisters exactly or her the
default was that yeah it was all guys in
the house and she didn't really care
yeah and even back she's I always asked
my mom and I and I feel like for a lot
of people that whole toilet seat up
toilet seat down thing has become like
this cultural thing now it's like oh
girls like it like this guys like it
like that
you know and for me it's it'll be up or
down yeah after I take a [ __ ] it's down
yes I just lift it up if I have to pee
exactly so I told them exactly the swap
you know that's what my thing was to it
I told him listen when I put this toilet
seat up and I leave it up I'm not doing
it as a as a point in contention to say
[ __ ] you yeah no I don't give a [ __ ]
that you're gonna fall through this
toilet a splash of vagina in the water
it's a stupid thing to fight over that's
what I'm saying yeah she goes it's just
my pet peeve I hate it I was like I
understand but when I mess up and I said
out of like a week I'll mess up twice
and that's out of seven days I'm taking
a piss at seven times yeah I think those
two times I [ __ ] up you should give me a
pass on you know like it doesn't happen
all the time I'm not doing it on purpose
to hurt you
it's just this is what I've been doing
my whole life so you're expecting me
just because you say it's your pet peeve
and it pisses you off
you're I'm not gonna be able to stop it
overnight I can only get better you know
as time goes on and it's not easy yeah
you know so like for example like she
did the most petty [ __ ] she
by the way I was cleaning the house all
day and I was setting up his podcast and
then I get a picture on my text message
she goes see you left the toilet seat
and I'm like [ __ ] you think that's what
I want to see right now oh no like while
you're at work I've been cleaning up the
boxes your little [ __ ] house and
you're giving me [ __ ] about this toilet
seat
I will body slam you into a bag of nails
like it's funny too like she takes it as
a personal attack it's not a personal
[ __ ] attack yeah sometimes people
slip up and people mess up yeah it's
like how many times have I told you
luggages is not a word it's luggage you
don't see me flanges yeah she goes did
you get the luggages it's luggage [ __ ]
I'm not over here just being like how
many [ __ ] times I tell you it's
[ __ ] lucky like it just right it's
like it's just like sometimes you slip
up you mess up that's all but sometimes
I feel like I just get the [ __ ] spear
right to the stomach this podcast is
brought to you by skylight frame check
it out man holidays are coming around
the corner and if you're looking for a
really dope gift for your family
especially if you want to share memories
and love you got to get a sky light
frame sky light frame is a photo frame
you can update instantly by email from
anywhere
it sets up effortlessly in about 60
seconds just plug in use the touchscreen
to connect to your wireless network and
enjoy sending photos the skylight is
super easy everyone in the family can
just email them to your personal
skylight email address and they'll pop
up in seconds now for me I actually got
this skylight frame for my parents
because whenever I go on vacations or I
travel all I have to do is send the
skylight or send to the skylight that
email address and the photos that I want
to send them pops up so when they have
the frame and they want to see things or
they want to see me they want to see me
and my fiance or the things that I'm
doing and they want to see photos they
don't have to wait for any other app or
you know whatever just to see what I'm
doing I could send it to the email and
it could pop up in the frame so they can
see it in real time which is really
really cool so check it out guys as a
special holiday offer you can get $10
off your purchase of a skylight frame
when you go to skylight frame comm and
enter code genius that's right to get
$10 off your purchase of a skylight
frame just go to skylight frame and calm
and
code genius that's s KY Li gh t F R a.m.
e.com promo code genius yeah it's like
hard I think it's always something else
man it's it's never the toilet see like
it's a representation and they you know
it makes them feel like something and it
doesn't makes her feel like I'm not
respecting her yeah it's like oh man
you're not thinking about me I think
when that happens - just looking back is
like you you probably don't give her
attention right now because you're so
busy right yeah so like that's kind of a
way for her to communicate like I need
to be priority I need to be known like
that's that's a big [ __ ] thing about
women that I wish I knew I wish I just I
mean I had a lot of time to think about
the relationship and where I [ __ ] up
and I think a big part of it is they
need to feel like they exist and
recognized and and and that you know
just they're there and and that's such
an emotionally like different thing I
think for guy is because our minds are
very one-track and also we don't need to
do that to each other and check in with
each other yeah
to know that we're we're here we exist
and we're significant yeah
so and also like those are traits I
think for men that that are kind of it
makes you feel less than to need that
from someone yeah right but women don't
grow up the same way or they don't you
know it's just different
right and you watch them interact and
they give that energy to each other
they've you know it's like oh I'm this
way nah girl you got this way he's like
that oh you so hot look at you you so
hot yeah like they [ __ ] shower each
other with that significance and then
don't like oh my God look at you did you
do something with your hair oh [ __ ] yeah
you know and they [ __ ] give that
[ __ ] like height man energy and then
they take us they take that step away to
just like look at them give them that
presence give them their attention all
that [ __ ] and in for me like it's
difficult to do that when I'm thinking
about how am I gonna fix this [ __ ]
business that winch sour
how the [ __ ] am I gonna do this whatever
right so my minds on that and then I go
oh [ __ ] I'm writing this book I'm
thinking about this book so I'm
like whatever and in like I come home I
don't even address her My Mind's on like
if I [ __ ] think about anything else
right now I have a TD it's gonna think
about that and then she'll be like hey
did you get that thing and I'm like huh
boom my mom's already gone what the [ __ ]
was I thinking about oh no I was
thinking about the book I had a great
million dollar idea where the [ __ ] did
that thought go oh no and then like it's
just different because women have that
capacity to multitask and think about
multiple things and switch back and
forth their emotions are they're capable
of feeling this and then two seconds
later feeling that for us we're like
it's it's completely different it's like
one [ __ ] long marathon that's going
one way and we can't run off track and
if we do we got to start all over again
yeah and I was like [ __ ] how do you
blend that dynamic it's different
yeah but they need to feel they need to
feel like wanted continuously and I was
like and that's their that's their way I
[ __ ] up that's because I would get mad
at that [ __ ] and I would fight it
logically and I was like that's just
their way of saying I need you and I'm
like [ __ ] I wish I knew that there's
this weird thing of like I think
sometimes people have this problem in a
relationship that that I used to have -
is where they they take certain like for
example she kind of brought up the fact
that she goes well he had a problem with
me grinding up on this girl who's a
bisexual girl but I don't feel for her
that way but that he goes off and he
cheats on me so who's he to say anything
right yeah and so sometimes people do
this thing where they look at the
negative stuff that somebody has done to
them and they hold on to it like it's
ammo oh I collect these these points oh
yeah oh remember when you did this
remember when you do that ruined you
know it's a very bad thing to do because
what you do is that you also kind of set
up the person that you're with or that
you care about for failure and there's
no way it's it's like a self-fulfilling
prophecy
remember that time [ __ ] up well it's
like [ __ ] you cuz I can do it too yeah
it's it's hard to address a problem
that's in front of you when you keep on
referring to stuff in the past that
hasn't been solved yeah and so if if if
we're doing the
thing where we're constantly going back
and forth and saying hey remember when
you did this remember when you did that
the fights never died down and they
become more and more intense and they
become compound over time over and over
and over
I remember when you came over and I
remember I was like all right well let's
talk about some of the stuff that you
guys went through you're like my [ __ ]
7 years ago I was like job and it just
was like yeah remember eight years old I
think I'm exaggerating but it was like
no no you're right we were just trying
to [ __ ] fight not resolve [ __ ]
because we were both hurt and we were
both selfishly concerned about being
heard being hurt on our own yeah and I
think that's where you know that's where
conflict resolution sucks and sucked in
our relationship and why it didn't work
is because like we're too concerned
about me first I'm hurt [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] hurt me
yeah and I think that's what people all
do all the time I want to be heard first
hmm I you know I want you to [ __ ]
recognize my pain first and I'm like
damn so that's why that's what they mean
by being the bigger person it's like oh
yeah I'm hurt but you know what like I
love you so tell me what happened that's
when those personal issues aren't
resolved it bleeds into other things and
things start to [ __ ] explode and yeah
because like for example yeah you know
this is like one of my funniest stories
that you ever told it was the [ __ ]
lime story dude oh my god taco like it's
never it's not even about the line yeah
I think it's just another [ __ ] just like
the last drop but you squeeze in that
lime and she's just laying the [ __ ] what
kind of what kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] is bad
you're like so unlike my [ __ ] large
[ __ ] I'm just saying well you could
just got a better live yeah you know but
it's not about that it's just there was
something else that wasn't resolved and
it just went boom yeah explodes and
these are the problems that happens and
for this guy whatever issue that you
guys were going through whatever need
that he felt that wasn't met and once
again I'm not saying this is saying that
you're at fault and you're to blame if
he was gonna cheat he was gonna cheat
either way but he thought it was an okay
team okay team that's okay okay team he
thought it was an okay thing to do to
find his comfort into somebody else's
arms I don't think he's even thinking
he's not
he's like oh I like your he's feeling
something that he wanted to feel from
you and then things just happened not to
excuse him but you know I don't think it
was something that he did to be spiteful
I don't think it's something that he did
to hurt you on purpose but when people
are emotionally distraught they did some
dumb [ __ ] things dude and maybe it
was like a situation where things
weren't curated correctly yeah that's
what happens on these personal
relationships that's right I am it's
rough man
but I kind of feel like it's time to
move on find somebody new but it's gonna
replicate itself it's like you learn
your lesson to move on yeah sometimes
when there's too much baggage in a
relationship it's hard to come back from
it it's hard I can't I'm somebody who I
wouldn't say I can't but it's harder for
me to I think if I was cheated let's say
Marielle cheated on me now I I want to
say that I would just cut it off and
move on but I really don't know yeah but
I I think I have more of a propensity to
do that just because it would like sit
with me very weird but who knows like I
I can't say stuff like that indefinite
and a lot of people have that gussto of
saying like oh if somebody did this to
me I would definitely do this that's
true cuz you don't know until it happens
exactly and I'm saying this to you like
I'm saying it to myself you're all
[ __ ] talk you don't know [ __ ] you
don't know [ __ ] you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're gonna do when it happens
because all these great memories might
start to pop up they might say the right
thing to make you forgive them you don't
really [ __ ] know yeah you could say
as much as you want oh I wish a
[ __ ] would do this because I
would do that that's what I thought too
when I said when I said to myself I said
you know what
I wish your [ __ ] will rob
somebody in front of me I was step in
and do something you know what happened
it wasn't a Jamba Juice this
[ __ ] got robbed in front of me
and I said what happened right away with
the guy's wallet I processed it hella
late I was like oh okay robbed you don't
know what's gonna happen I literally saw
this guy get [ __ ] robbed you guys
Wallace don't in front of a Jamba Juice
in South Pasadena right in front of me
and I just couldn't process what this
pocket he picked his [ __ ] [ __ ] like
he just basically jacked him well I
don't know what was going on and I was
just like oh my god this just happened
and I I was like for some reason I find
out who explains to me it was like
called like normal seat like you try to
normalize everything
and so mas can't accept your brain
doesn't accept that it's happening
exactly and that happens with shocking
events like cheating you don't know what
you're gonna do until that should happen
so you know don't don't be so cocky and
confident about your situation giving
people advice about [ __ ] that you
haven't been through I read this comment
recently he goes you know what I'm like
a 26 year old virgin I haven't had a
girlfriend yet but let me tell you my
two cents your two cents doesn't mean
[ __ ] all right
it literally does it why do people with
no experience feel like they should give
you an opinion I don't [ __ ] know dude
it's not see that's the part about
America that I [ __ ] hate is you are
not entitled to your own [ __ ] opinion
you I mean well you can you can say what
you want but you're a [ __ ] idiot
yeah you know I mean well we all get to
say where the [ __ ] we are but I mean
damn man like know you're [ __ ] roll
man if you never been through it shut
the [ __ ] up
yeah save yourself the damn
embarrassment yeah what are you trying
to solve other people's problems but
like don't don't sit there and try to
solve somebody else's problems when you
haven't even live anything close to a
day in their shoes man like you're
trying to give a billionaire advice
about money and you have you don't even
even had a job yet exactly they haven't
even made your first dollar yet yeah is
that the funny thing that people do well
I hope that helped you out lacoya on but
on to the next genius suggestion whoo I
was a good one I like this one dude
dating after college oh yeah ooh dating
in a dating game this month I'll go back
in the dating game ha ha ha I like dates
this person's name is just Dee I'm gonna
say that your name is dick so dick
dating after college I haven't gone on a
date for 10 years because I wanted to
focus on school and my career 10 years
and [ __ ] you wait a minute that means
you never had a girlfriend in your whole
entire life what are you talking about
high schools for years yeah
college is about four years so that
means from junior high he's counting
sixth grade as dating am i doing the
math wrong here what a [ __ ] Danny after
college so what he's 21 10 years 11
[ __ ] that don't [ __ ] caliber so you
basically been single forever dude get
the [ __ ]
I've been I been out of the dating game
for ten years miss you weren't even in
the game though you weren't even a
[ __ ] bench player you phrased it is
funny like Danny hasn't caught me honest
with yourself he's like I never [ __ ]
went on a date and I just graduated
college never had a girlfriend that's
cool man don't worry about it you know
there's some people that choose not to
date for a long time or there I had a
friend who hasn't had a first girlfriend
until he's 25 years old because he just
didn't like dealing with um crazy
emotions and [ __ ] and and there's
nothing to be ashamed of but to mask it
him go yo I've been out of the dating
game in ten years it's like what are you
talking about man you were 11 or 10
years old listen man I just graduated
high school I mean out of the dating
game for 18 years [ __ ] again because I
don't know what it's like last time I
saw [ __ ] I was inside one so I came out
of one so [ __ ] funny dude okay well
never mind okay he says and cuz I've
been putting minimal effort in dating
okay he's at school and career so maybe
he's stuck maybe he added some okay I
hope okay now we're rooting more my bed
that we were supposed to do for no
reason but as [ __ ] funny now I'm 30
now that's funny okay that's funny
so he's dating around 20 okay and then
he for 10 years you took a break yeah
okay so he's he now he's 30 so it was
when he was 19 was the last time you
dated
okay now I'm 30 and I don't know where
to start friends circles are already
explored okay [ __ ] he's like all the
finest girls are my friends circle are
taken he [ __ ] homie hop and ass
[ __ ]
alright that's the funny thing you say
you know what's cool though if he's
really focused on his career that means
he's 30 and he's got money I know look
take this out so I work at a hospital
he's a nurse [ __ ] awesome and
consider work relationships kind of
risky but it's almost not even options
and most of the women I meet at work in
my age range have boyfriends fiance's or
husbands pretty early into their careers
yeah 30s are the are the most least
single ladies manful you got to go find
a 12 year old bro yep I find I find it
hard to see my
meaning a woman just out by the way
that's a joke just in case people want
to roast me on that [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
joke
I don't like 12 year olds I like 13 okay
what do we are Kelly you know what do
you think I am I find it hard to see
myself meeting a woman just out in the
wild okay unless there's a place we both
frequent and something can be built over
time I'm just really skeptical of people
not wild about dating or meet-up apps
open to suggestions things hey he was
I'm male to clarify hey you're [ __ ]
just to let you know why would he limit
yourself he's like okay so I don't know
where to start
my friend is you know dating circle
sucks like I don't really like the bar
you know and I don't like dating apps so
yeah I'm [ __ ] where do I start guys
yeah I don't know the [ __ ] Amazon
jungle maybe you've had more of a damn
chance there no like I wouldn't okay so
me I was reluctant for tinder and [ __ ]
like that because you kind of have a
name to yourself I do right but at the
same time my friends like do you want a
[ __ ] or not and I was thinking yeah I
do
yeah I do and he's like why would you
limit yourself yeah it's like if a girl
you meet her she's [ __ ] awesome she's
cool like wouldn't you want to expand
your chances you're gonna let your pride
get to you and prevent you to meet your
next dream girl why because you have too
much pride and I'm like oh you know what
you're right cuz he met his girlfriend
on tinder so I don't think he wanted to
seem like a loser but he gave me that
speech right I was like okay I'm gonna
make an account [ __ ] it and then you
know like it's we do this thing I think
a lot of us guys were we just want to
get over the dating part and get with
that dream you know like we know it's
like that shit's such a it's it's so
annoying you have to like go on dates
you had to do this and it's like but now
I have a totally different approach to
it because it's fun like I like to meet
people and I'm not thinking about who's
my next wife I'm thinking about these
people are awesome like so many
different like life's lifestyles and
ideas and thoughts and like you know
like I get to talk to like adventurers
and travelers or like [ __ ] straight
up you
no like surfer girls or business girls
or whatever you know and and you just
sit there and you engage with them and
then you just have a good time getting
to know people but like a lot of us I
think we're too quick to think of ten
years ahead and being like well am I
gonna waste time on you because like how
do you know yeah how would you know so
like I would say when you're thinking
about dating like don't limit yourself
man like don't hating do you want yet I
think the best line is why would you
stop yourself from meeting your dream
girl yeah cuz yeah that's exactly what
you're doing and in some people I won't
meet my dream girl or at a bar
well I won't mean my dream girl at this
place it's like how would you [ __ ]
know you haven't tried your approach is
so [ __ ] dumb man and I want to say
here's why let me just say this like
this is this is genius suggestions right
take this with a grain of salt actually
you know what not a grain of salt take
this with the whole [ __ ] Morten
[ __ ] Diamond kosher salt you [ __ ]
jackass like this is what you're doing
you're going into this [ __ ] pond
that's dried up this is this is your
area that you like you go these are the
scenarios in which I want to meet
somebody right and that's it
and then you're wondering how you're
going to get this big catch so instead
of going into a bigger pond to having a
higher probability of catching somebody
that you want casting multiple rods well
you're going is to this dried up [ __ ]
mud pond and throwing out your [ __ ]
rod and wondering why you can't catch
anything yeah it's it's it's dumb it's
it's [ __ ] stupid
it's so dumb to the point where you are
trying to set up a perfect scenario in
your head of how you want a woman to
approach you and talk to you and how you
want to develop a relationship that's
not [ __ ] realistic so if you want to
go into a situation where the
probability is that low then you have to
understand it and accept it yeah so you
are putting yourself into this box you
can't beggars can't be choosers exactly
uh you you cannot and here's the problem
with this - and this is how I'm seeing
it - if you approach dating this way I
would hate to see how you are in an
actual relationship if you approach
dating as in these are the parameters
that you have to be in or I'm not going
to be happy - it translates into your
future relationship if you're mister
long-term relationship guy you will be
the last person that anybody will want
to be with because you need to set up
your perfect standards for how things
should always be to make
happy and that's not how life is and
that's [ __ ] not how dating is dating
is more about finding out what you like
and then you finding out about the other
person you will find that out for me
growing up I used to think that I wanted
a specific type of girl and it turns out
I [ __ ] hate that girl I thought I
wanted a girl who was just super sweet
all the time that she was the exact
opposite of me in the sense of you know
I guess I kind of wanted her to be more
compliant you know but she's a
submissive housewife oh I want to say
that far but she's like fighting because
my mom fought so much less arguing all
the time and I was like I don't want to
be with a woman like that turns out I
like [ __ ] yeah like I like Mary ol
fights me all the time you're just in a
very loving way I love you Mary oh but
she a woman who stands her ground yeah
she stands her ground and she tests me
all that and sometimes mean yes and
sometimes says things you don't want to
hear yeah that makes you just want to
[ __ ] uppercut them and sometimes
makes you feel like less of a man that
was the girl that I was with before
Muriel she was so sweet to a [ __ ]
fault and it was because I thought that
that was a type of woman that I wanted
to be with hmm she it was which is a
point where we would argue about
something and I say my point and she
would just be like you know what you're
right I'm completely wrong and it was
like that with everything and then I was
sitting back it's difficult to respect
people like that exactly I couldn't
[ __ ] respect her I was like if you
have a point let me hear it out don't
you agree with what I'm saying I want to
know why you thought that so at least I
could get a better understanding of who
you are and the only way that I got to
understand what I wanted it in a person
was by dating people being open to the
thought of dating people in these
situations that I would have never known
I've mentioned this before on the
podcast I have [ __ ] mad anxiety I
have I have to beat that [ __ ] out of me
and I got to figure out what I wanted in
a partner and who I was as a person
because I dated in these very awkward
situations I started dating people that
I met at my community college I started
dating people that I would meet at
comedy clubs I started dating people
anytime any chance that I could get yeah
if I thought that they were attractive
and fun almost like let me shoot my shot
and see what happens
and I was able to develop a more solid
idea of what I wanted in a person who I
was yeah I think that's it is like don't
even think of it like the next girl that
you
meat better not waste their time and you
have to marry her just yeah a lot of
guys jump the gone man even on the first
date dirty planning the [ __ ] marriage
and that's where creep zone happens man
like and or they're just so desperate
for [ __ ] vagina they're like I can't
wait til I get her home and [ __ ] to
shatter her and they want a one-night
stand or something it's like I think
that dating a lot and meaning a lot and
brushing up on those social skills and
taking rejection and being stronger
that's what makes a man and if you can't
[ __ ] do that you don't deserve a good
woman and she's like he's saying I you
know what you don't want to waste your
time dating is not a waste of time it's
a life experience it's great and you
meet more people you might you might not
end up [ __ ] or being with there but
you might end up with a dope-ass friend
where you vibe it in like you know
things can come from that you know like
it's like it's it's hard to explain man
but I think a lot of guys that don't
enter that realm their problem is also
they don't interact with enough women in
people yeah so they like the more years
you wait the you know people keep
surpassing you with social dynamic and
all those skills that you don't you
don't [ __ ] you can't be the best person
for your next girlfriend homie hopper
dude and stop being a [ __ ] homie
hopper dude what's wrong with you man
it's like dude I have no friends to date
anymore everybody's taking up taken up
it's like dog you know there's other
women out there besides the [ __ ]
women that your friends have already
[ __ ] especially now dating so much
easy because before you were limited to
not only your city but your social
circle your race your class you know you
can now you can like it's easy to be in
a multicultural like [ __ ] interracial
relationship with I mean like you can
date someone from someone far away it's
like it's much easier now you find more
people that you vibe with because of
online and you know what - its if you're
the person - that wants to find like you
want to cut through the [ __ ] and
find somebody that you're compatible
with why wouldn't you want to do dating
apps dating ads are curated by based on
what you want in a person and they try
to match it up to the best way possible
so they do about 20% of the work that
you would have to do prior to that
because when you
do that all in your underwear at home
exactly and it's quick and the
probability is a lot higher
you know what [ __ ] had to do back in
the day you had a dress nice walk to the
[ __ ] bar like what a club or whatever
and you had to sit there and to [ __ ]
talk to almost every [ __ ] woman out
there and then see if it vibes or
doesn't vibe
you waste a lot of time doing a lot
these [ __ ] apps meant like there's a
there's a dating app for every single
type out that you would have a dating
app called foreskin meets for skin yeah
it'll be a girl with the [ __ ]
pastrami much [ __ ] and then a [ __ ]
guy with long foreskin on his dick and
that's the only requirements that you
really want these things are so
Christian mingle I saw like conspiracy
singles and it was like it was a white
couple with [ __ ] foil on their heads
and [ __ ] that's what I'm saying like if
you want those specific parameters for
who you want to date then the dating app
is already for you at that point I would
have loved one time somebody used my
profile I got my Facebook account hacked
and they use it and they cooked they
hooked up my facebook to tinder oh [ __ ]
and I was getting all this other [ __ ]
and I got linked up [ __ ] somebody
came out Danielle she was on tinder -
and then my profile pops up and Danielle
was like why are you on tinder I was
like I'm not on [ __ ] tinder area what
are you talking about
but somebody hacked into my facebook and
they leaked on my tinder and they all
like these random stats about me or
whatever and then there was a bunch of
[ __ ] random swipes you know and
you're like I could have all these girls
look at that I could be dating that's
kind of cool
and it's funny too when I read the
profile it was it was pretty accurate to
who I was it person so this person
obviously was a fan yeah you know cuz
they they like I knew you they knew me
they were like certain quirks about me
have phishing girls on your faced ham
they're so [ __ ] funny I don't know
what the purpose of that was but it was
kind of a nice ego boost yeah I was like
oh that's kind of cool I guess if I
wanted to get into dating I could again
but yeah and I mean I will focus on that
it's all about like I mean a lot of the
times like you're just thinking about
the girl to meet your criteria right but
like I always tell people is if you're
single like write down all the things
that you want in a person and then that
person will start showing up more and
put it out there in the world like tell
your friends does the person is the girl
I'm looking forward to the girl I'm
looking for
and you gotta be the man that's right
for them to like you know take a look at
yourself in the mirror smell yourself
are you the best you can be yeah you
know like can you lose some weight can
you gain some muscle can you do
something can you you know whatever like
in women like men who are driven and
have interests and things like that like
you have a great career all that but you
also if you're a nurse you have a lot of
days free right like you're probably on
a 3/12 schedule or a 410 or some [ __ ]
like that but you have multiple days
open pick up a hobby pick up a skill
pick up other things like start another
business do something do do whatever it
is you know and then like um because
you're yeah you're the classic king of
like have-nots like oh I can't I can't
do this I can't do that but I want to do
it this way it's like been [ __ ] don't
come a lot of people are like that man
it's [ __ ] hate passion but I I think
it's because they don't know that they
are doing that in their letting
themselves and it's it all stems from
fear fear of rejection yeah just go out
there even it's fun yeah it's gone even
if you know that this dating thing is
might fail you might be surprised and
what you find out when you date
I really enjoyed dating invited to it
was really fun for me like if anything
else like oh I'll never give up Mariel
but do I miss dating I actually do I
missed that that fresh interaction
sometimes but for me the reason why you
know obviously I don't go to live in
that lifestyle is because what I have
with Mariel is ten million times better
than those those glimpses of happiness
when I date like nothing I will never
replace what I have now with that
[ __ ] little [ __ ] right there
but if you're if you're 30 you're still
young you're still young you're already
five dude and I'm dating
yeah he's 35 like I'm turning my [ __ ]
date till I'm 45 I don't go [ __ ] I get
rejected all the time to like people
always make oh oh oh you have a
following and like girls like because I
mean nah bro like [ __ ] there's girls
that are like have way bigger followings
than me or just other things and um and
I ain't [ __ ] to them but still like I
just keep talking and in in like for me
I'm not thinking about [ __ ] everybody
I'm not thinking about marrying
everybody I'm just talking and seeing if
I couldn't act or if I don't and all I
care about is connecting
that's what you should worry about is
emotionally mentally and physically
connecting yeah and you can't do that if
you're already looking to be married to
somebody ten years ahead when you
haven't even talked to this person yet
dude like I it's great to have that goal
and understanding where you want to be
in your relationship with the person but
to sit there and say like well I want to
get married and that you're already
setting up an expectation that would you
want to get married let's start with
that oh why [ __ ] tie yourself down to
one [ __ ] fool forget it just cut out a
man have fun yeah and lift each other up
in life damn yeah it's not it's all good
you act like 30 is hella old - it's not
man you're [ __ ] what you're what
you're now - you're two years younger
than me that's whatever I was I wasn't
even thinking about getting into a
serious relationship till I was 30 Diana
yeah but then Muriel just happened to
come by and I met her when I was 25 22
26 Wow so is what it is you don't even
feel like I'm 35 well I don't act like
I'm very vibrator well you don't look
like you're 35 thank you thank you thank
you but you've seen some of our homies
do oh my god oh [ __ ] I hate it - when I
meet somebody who's our age or on our
age like in the 30s and they go yep
we're old guys [ __ ] your old look [ __ ]
are you talking about but you don't drag
me in this world
I hate that dude they're like huh Muriel
sometimes to do that she does that [ __ ]
- she goes god I'm so old I'm like if
you keep saying that dude you know what
the version of a [ __ ] [ __ ] drying up
for a male is and my foreskin is
receding back into my belly button
that's what you're doing you [ __ ] at
least lie about it yeah you're not
you're not old I want to see a 90 year
old grandma talk about how young she is
- yeah that's my [ __ ] right there dude I
got to work with the with with the lady
in her 70s recently and she she's
amazing dude she [ __ ] kills it like
she's super dope to be around and she
has the energy of like a [ __ ] 12 year
old that's great that's though it's a
mentality noon it is being [ __ ] well
guys that wraps this episode of the
genius brain podcast with all these
genius suggestions I like these yeah I
like it a lot - gives us something to
focus on when we talk about our personal
stuff instead of just going on a random
diatribe but I know you guys like - but
[ __ ] you day if you guys want us to talk
about certain topics
people on the patreon get first dibs
after that leave it in the comments
below interact I like it when people
talk in the comments too if you guys
have an opinion just go talk back and
forth don't [ __ ] yell and scream at
each other but just have an opinion
about things and be able to defend your
point that's all that it is man great
conversations you can catch us on
Spotify iTunes any stitcher any type of
audio platform out there were there if
you're on iTunes make sure you give us a
5 a 5 star and share the podcast with
all your friends because we're trying to
be there for you you know I'm saying
yeah sexy son of the [ __ ] we'll see
y'all next time
toodaloo mana asses peace